we are back now at 7 30 here on CBS
mornings and we're talking about a
growing danger something that parents
need to be aware of it involves cars and
trucks which get bigger every year and
as they do so the blind spots are
getting larger as well even in the front
of the vehicles we visited a top Testing
Lab to get a better idea of what drivers
can see and what they cannot see right
in front of them as Chris Van Cleef
reports this is a problem responsible
for hundreds of traffic fatalities every
year
four-year-old Hudson foshee was a
vibrant little boy
lost in a preventable accident in
January 2019 his mother Jackie was
pulling into the driveway she thinks
Hudson ran to get the mail but from
inside her full-size SUV she says she
never saw him I was kind of like running
around everywhere looking for him and
then
I looked under the car and he was there
vehicles have a blind Zone directly in
front of the hood that grows with the
size of the car Americans shift to
larger trucks and SUVs comes as debts
from these front over crashes more than
doubled in five years killing over 500
in 2020. experts say the victims are
often small children
I miss my son
this is hugs
I miss watching him grow up and
what would he have been I don't know
what my child would have been or
what he would have grown up to be
inside their test facility Consumer
Reports shows us how much a driver can't
see watch as these four young children
LeapFrog forward another four full spots
and they're still out of view I can see
Dylan's head so do we get nine kids
there that zone is far longer than you
think Consumer Reports tested the front
blind zones of 15 Vehicles ranging from
about three feet for a small sports car
to as much as 15 feet for one full-size
pickup there are the equivalent of eight
kids in front of this car right now I
can't see a single one Barry Rosen is
Consumer Reports communications director
and the mom of ten-year-old Dylan who is
hidden from her view as she sits in this
pickup truck
that's insane that's absolutely
horrifying Consumer Reports showed us
three different demos the larger the car
the larger the blind Zone do you think
there's a good enough understanding
amongst drivers about the area they
cannot see
like so I think people feel actually
much better protected in the larger
vehicle but what they're not realizing
is now the area directly around them has
been compromised they cannot see that as
well as they would have been a shorter
smaller lower Hood height vehicle the
technology is there it is fully
affordable Connecticut Senator Richard
Blumenthal is now proposing legislation
to make front-facing cameras and
collision avoidance sensors standard the
technology already exists but the camera
is often inexpensive add-on it's similar
to backup cameras required on all new
vehicles since 2018. safety should not
be a premium feature it should be
standard just like airbags and seat
belts Jackie foschi agrees and hopes her
family's tragedy can help make cars
safer I would never want another parent
to experience
this
it's terrible
automakers tell CBS News safety is a top
priority and vehicles continue to get
even more safe as automakers tests
develop and integrate new safety
Technologies if you don't have a
forward-facing camera in your vehicle
already safety experts and the Auto
industry recommend doing a walk around
the car before you get in for CBS
mornings I'm Chris Van Cleave in
Washington
right but of course a lot of people just
got to get where they're going and
you're rushing and rushing and they're
thinking the car they think what they
can see out their windshield is
everything they need to see and what
Chris just laid out in an incredible
detail is that there's a huge Zone
particularly these bigger vehicles of
what you can't see and the result can be
unbelievable tragedy as we see
devastating I'm so glad the mother is
sharing her story because I can't
imagine the feeling the horror that you
realize after you're looking for your
child and I thought Senator Blumenthal
is correct safety features should not be
an option that shouldn't be an extra
that shouldn't be something yeah that
should exactly absolutely be standard
especially as these cars get more
technologically advanced we should have
the cameras and the sensors in the front
of the car just like we have in the back
it shouldn't be another money making
opportunity you put the tech in and then
you sell it it should be a standard part
of what the safety package is the
Baseline no doubt but guys I didn't
realize you couldn't see in front of the
car I thought that's what I thought was
so interesting yeah I know about the
back but I didn't realize if you have a
big SUV you can't really see rights in
front of what's right underneath your
windshield
drivers don't realize yes very strong
piece